[Música]
faltou eu sei quem vai ser o próximo
presidente do brasil para seu próximo é
necessário convencer a maioria de apenas
100 pessoas num país como o brasil com
200 milhões de pessoas
vocês também sabem não é à toa que quase
33 por cento dos eleitores não votaram
nas últimas eleições
esse é um fenômeno que está acontecendo
ao redor do mundo as pessoas estão
desistindo da política porque nós
estamos mantendo apenas os velhos lá a
representatividade ela não representa
mais o nosso sistema atual de política e
de criação de novos políticos esse
ecossistema que nós convivemos não
funciona mais
ninguém mais acredita nele atualmente
essa representatividade
ela está nesse grupo pequeno por exemplo
por uma empreiteira a cada um real numa
campanha eleitoral
o retorno e oito reais em contratos
públicos
da mesma maneira que as leis elas não
caem do céu e elas raramente são neutras
para vocês terem uma idéia nos últimos
anos mais de 50% de todas as medidas
provisórias no nosso congresso tiveram
os mesmos a mesma natureza econômica dos
doadores dos seus relatores e esse dado
está cada vez pior
em 2014 dez empresas que financiaram 70%
dos deputados federais
a questão aqui é que está muito claro
quem está conseguindo conquistar essa
representatividade e não é à toa e nem
coincidência que muitos desses
influenciadores estão inclusive
assumindo a sua culpa as campanhas
eleitorais
a maior operação investigativa contra a
corrupção no brasil que a operação lava
jato e aí fica a pergunta a tecnologia
pode transformar algo na política a
gente vive numa era em que tu
está sendo transformado tudo está sendo
impactado pela tecnologia mas nós não
estamos enxergando nenhuma solução de
como nós podemos impactar política na
minha opinião só há um jeito
nós só vamos conseguir impactar política
nossa representatividade
se criarmos tecnologia para tornar e e
se tornar um ecossistema na nossa
sociedade onde é possível a criação de
novos políticos a todo momento
se nós continuarmos utilizando
tecnologia apenas a favor de notícias
falsas manipulação robôs marketing
comunicação à política ela não vai se
transformar
nós também vivemos dizendo por aí que as
mulheres são minorias
nós dizemos que os negros são minorias
mas todos nós sabemos que isso não é
verdade eles nós fizemos isso porque
eles não são representados na política e
uma coisa que é muito importante a
democracia não é um esporte para a gente
ficar acompanhando na tv a democracia
ela exige o envolvimento
nós não podemos encarar a democracia
criticando ela nos bares criticando ela
na casa da família a gente tem que se
envolver a democracia ela é uma
construção eterna
para você ter uma idéia do desafio
financeiro atual aqui no brasil para
eleger um deputado federal é necessário
em média 6 milhões e quatrocentos mil
reais
esse número só vem aumentando tornando
um obstáculo à construção de novos
políticos da mesma maneira no brasil ao
fundo partidário que é o fundo de
financiamento de políticos
aqui no brasil esse fundo ele é
determinado o valor pelos próprios
políticos anualmente queira você ou não
todos nós já doamos para campanhas
eleitorais em 2016 esse número foi de
819 milhões ou seja cada um aqui do holo
no mínimo quatro reais
qual é a diferença do fundo partidário
do financiamento direto o financiamento
direto permite a construção coletiva
do seu representante o financiamento da
maneira que funciona hoje não representa
ninguém pode influenciar as campanhas
para vocês terem uma idéia de como eu
acredito que há pistas de que a gente
pode acreditar no fato de que a
tecnologia pode construir um novo
ecossistema é nós analisarmos alguns
movimentos de construção de rede no
mundo digital
um deles no brasil em 2015 por exemplo
nós conseguimos financiar mais de 25 mil
projetos de diversos propósitos em redes
aqui no brasil utilizando a plataforma
de crowdfunding nos estados unidos em
2008 o obama conseguiu a eleição dele
com mais de três milhões e meio de
financiadores em 21 meses ele conseguiu
arrecadar 750 milhões de dólares
isso só foi possível porque a tecnologia
estava lá
aqui no brasil nós construímos uma lei
que se chama marco civil que regula o
uso da internet
ela foi construída por mais de 10 mil
colaboradores em plataformas online
também tivemos a lei do ficha limpa que
foi apoiada por mais de um milhão e 600
mil brasileiros
a política é um financiamento em rede a
grande questão é que hoje essa rede é
muito pequena ea gente precisa mais
ficar isso nós precisamos tornar isso
algo que a todos e não para poucos em
tive a oportunidade de liderar um dos
projetos que acredito que são
importantes para impactar nossa
representatividade o nome dele se chama
voto legal é um software livre que nós
construímos com diversas organizações da
sociedade civil entre elas a mcc
o movimento contra a corrupção eleitoral
o nosso objetivo era a construção de
candidatos que tinham como proposta
clara de carreira política ter eleições
mais justas e transparentes e nós
precisávamos de tecnologia para isso
nós desenvolvemos uma interface que cada
candidato poderia colocar em um vídeo
explicando porque ele queria receber o
seu dinheiro realizando uma campanha de
doação além de uma campanha de voto
ao mesmo tempo a gente estimula uma
linguagem cidadã para que todos entendem
esse motivo todos os projetos que ele
tinha placa praga
o mandato dele estavam claros ou seja
nós queremos criar uma memória de
campanha
ao mesmo tempo qualquer candidato que
quiser entrar na plataforma teria que
disponibilizar um planejamento
financeiro da sua campanha planejamento
de custo seus doadores o que está
gastando mais em 2016 foi um ano um
pouco difícil no brasil
a gente teve uma eleição de apenas 45
dias que a nossa lei eleitoral também
coloca diversas restrições para os
políticos que só pode captar recursos
financeiros na época da eleição
então os políticos são 45 dias para que
eles pudessem pedir voto e pedir
dinheiro ao mesmo tempo a gente teve as
olimpíadas no rio de janeiro
nós tivemos um processo de impeachment e
ainda assim uma mudança drástica na lei
eleitoral proibindo as empresas de
participarem desse processo mas durante
esse período e ouvir histórias
fantásticas acontecendo aqui no brasil
uma delas é da hora carolina apenas 32
anos negra feminista vindo do movimento
de hip hop primeira candidatura dela
através de um coletivo e uma rede de
pessoas chamado cidade que queremos não
seguiu se a vereadora mais votada em
belo horizonte
ela também se utilizou da plataforma do
voto legal mas a questão é que hoje esse
fenômeno ele é isolado é exceção ele não
é um padrão ea gente precisa expandir
essa tecnologia para o maior número de
candidatos políticos novos e para que
isso aconteça eu preciso da ajuda de
vocês
nós precisamos estimular as pequenas
doações a maioria das pessoas hoje têm
uma dificuldade enorme em querer atuar
por um político
nem a gente não confia nessa classe mas
ao mesmo tempo que os políticos têm uma
dificuldade muito grande de solicitar
dinheiro inclusive alguns que dizem que
não querem dinheiro de ninguém para ser
eleito à cultura de doação ela é uma
questão que a gente observou que durante
as eleições os candidatos que
conseguiram realizar uma campanha focada
em doação tiveram retorno espetacular e
isso também passa por dois grandes
desafios que nós temos atualmente que
são os crimes eleitorais
o primeiro caixa dois ou seja o
recebimento de dinheiro através de meios
ilícitos e que não são contabilizados na
prestação de contas dificultando a
fiscalização o outro o uso de laranjas
muitos políticos que pedem seu nome
emprestado pra justificar doações que
receberam e aí fica muito claro que
durante todo esse processo de construção
a gente tem apenas dois caminhos daqui
pra frente é nós continuarmos tendo uma
moeda de poder onde grandes empresas e
grandes indivíduos conseguem financiar a
política ou a criação de uma moeda de
representatividade moeda de
representatividade que seja 10 reais 15
reais para poder criar novos políticos
pensando nisso nós fomos buscar
tecnologias existentes e experiências
que pudessem facilitar e impactar a
confiança das pessoas nos políticos
nesse processo eleitoral em 2008 foi
criada uma moeda chamada bitcoin essa
moeda ela ela não funciona dentro de um
banco ela não precisa de um governo
ela funciona de maneira autônoma nós
usamos essa tecnologia para poder tornar
o processo mais transparente e confiável
o blog tem provavelmente vai ser a
tecnologia que vai impactar o direito a
contabilidade do sistema financeiro
assim como internet e impactou o
comércio a publicidade à comunicação
o exemplo muito simples imagina se
durante as eleições
quando você depositasse o seu
voto numa urna esse voto fosse
registrado em todas as urnas do país
isso tornaria o processo muito mais
confiável que é o que acontece hoje e é
isso que essa tecnologia pode garantir
para nós
o voto legal foi desenvolvido em
software livre ou seja qualquer um pode
utilizar a outra questão que nós
elaboramos um contrato inteligente onde
fosse possível a rastreabilidade todas
as doações em tempo real ou seja todos
os candidatos que utilizará a plataforma
assumir um compromisso em tempo real eu
estou disponibilizando todas as minhas
informações financeiras porque
transparência num processo transparência
não exige um relatório no final das
eleições pra todo mundo pra gente
verificar o que aconteceu em vídeo os
crimes que estão sendo julgados agora no
tse
nós não podemos exigir que todo mundo só
mande algo para nós explica que depois a
gente precisa tornar o sistema eleitoral
transparente por completo em tempo real
você fez uma doação e essa informação
está indo pra todos ao mesmo tempo e nós
já temos tecnologia para isso
o processo eleitoral é uma guerra entre
grupos políticos e isso que é importante
porque a gente precisa da informação
precisa grupos políticos porque além de
nós quem vai fiscalizar os próprios
políticos são eles as oposições entre
eles um fato super curioso é que nós
observamos já na edição de 2016 que os
candidatos que receberam o maior número
de doadores tiveram até cinco vezes o
custo do voto menor dos que receberam
mães ou seja uma dica para os políticos
solicitem doação que vocês vão ter um
custo de voto menor
as doações nas eleições de 2016 também
80% delas são consideradas de pequeno
valor e apenas 20 são com valores
milionários
apesar da reforma na lei ficou claro que
nós não podemos trocar empreiteiras por
milionários
nós temos que fazer algo para que tenham
tenhamos limites na doação porque a
doação ela tem que ser um ato de apoio
ela não pode ser um ato de poder durante
o processo do voto legal nós tivemos aí
os candidatos inscritos de quase 27
partidos 130 utilizar a plataforma do
voto legal um ano de 2016
entre eles o mais votado vereador em são
paulo assim como o mais votado em belo
horizonte
nós tivemos transacionados na plataforma
dentre esses candidatos um valor pequeno
perto dos quase 500 mil candidatos que
nós temos no brasil hoje
mas o que foi importante dentro desse
processo é que nós conseguimos comprovar
que pode haver tecnologia que consiga
posicionar um político para buscar a
doação que ele consiga realizar toda a
campanha dele utilizando tecnologias
para oferecer segurança aos seus
eleitores e confiabilidade
a moeda da representatividade são as
pequenas doações
então por isso que eu convido vocês a
estimular e apoiar em ea realizarem
doações para os seus próximos candidatos
porque senão as candidaturas do nosso
próximo presidente vai ser previsível
para ser quem conseguir mais dinheiro
obrigado
[Música]
[Aplausos]